the torque and like the for like it was
just ferocious when you got something it
was like you weren't doing it just to
win it was like see that's the thing and
I keep that mentality now when I train
guys I hear people go oh I didn't get
you to tap I'm like see right there your
vocabulary it tells me your brain's not
in the right spot tapping is not an
objective tapping is for the guy on the
other side to protect himself during
training yeah there's no other option no
I'm not trying to make you tap I'm
trying to break your arm even in
training I'm going to break your arm and
if you tap I'll stop yep right because
that should be the objective in your
mind I'm trying to destroy that limb so
there's one less limb between me and
your throat you know what I mean because
eventually I want to get to your neck to
cut off the blood of your brain if you
train for tapping now you're making it
too much sportative and you're just
trying to hurt people like oh I want you
to cry Uncle why are you trying to get a
cry Uncle what does uncle mean you know
I mean like I'm trying to make you
unconscious